[Music]
in DJ grandma news tip to Grandma
submitted by Oh what up an 82 year old
woman finally found her calling as a DJ
in downtown Tokyo yep 82 chef purple
hair why I just figured a lot of
grandmas just [ __ ] up on the hair dye
and they mean for it to be brown but it
turns out blue that was my grandma that
she was purple I don't know how she got
perfect hit Christmas yeah really yeah
the wrong hair colors or an orange
it's like purple or orange yeah no
personally I do think this is a great
idea and I have been thinking that old
people being DJs would be great
why what they can't hear anyway so they
don't need like the fun it's just like I
know what they're playing is good
because they can hear it the best
because it's not overloading their [ __ ]
so it's just normal to them but they
don't even know like understand the
music you know if you're like back okay
alright even like today like are they
really hip with the time and the really
one disco night and as a reference the
reason why old people [ __ ] up their hair
color is because they look at the box
and they'll realize that they have white
hair to begin with yeah because like the
extreme [ __ ] color that's why old
people I got you back you guys and all
this fuss management they look who is
[ __ ] they're in style now so they got a
diet twice they dyed black yeah what is
it call it just won't be that color so
for example right let's say they want to
get like a reddish brown hair but if
your hair is white it's just going to be
straight rent that's right so there's no
degree for it to happen that way oh my
mom just left it stayed because like she
dies it black and then it starts fading
and then it just becomes like clothes
brown color yeah so they would have to
use one color first and then dye it
again
oh you know what a power [ __ ] my
grandma is was sort of y'all get used to
it another one everyone was calling her
out on her purple ass hair dye right and
then she was like I meant it to be like
that I see all the young people doing it
nowadays I meant to do it like that all
you're proud [ __ ] dude I don't even
want to add meat your mistakes
I meant to the Anglin
- so this DJ so her name is sue Michael
um muru - dj name yo Dre - Miko keroppi
based on her name what do you think did
you call duh DJ strawberry strawberry DJ
[ __ ] talker
I don't know didn't even work this is it
I have no idea actually whatever you
feel in your heart
- those like me were in the game it's
like the name of your street your
favorite color your assert your first of
all what she did to get her did you know
she's like the her dj name is DJ suni
rock oh no that's really him I don't
know how I feel like a b-boy I'm the ho
so sue me is her first name Kumiko yeah
and then for her last name uwah was
translated i apparently - rock star
translated it in the nut house
do meet me rock do you have a video of
her set yes oh my god we tie you this is
what I need to see everybody be quiet
easy - that was pretty good video that
feeling if it starts all disappoint me
that's not kind of weird because she she
uses a strobe boys um like look so dope
she looks like an old school airman yes
I'm saying because Astro Boy was created
in the same area where she grew up so
that's why she uses like that whole
intro but in Japanese I feel old
doo-shik enough she's 83 there to feed
again this is ty told you she'll have a
lot yeah you're right tuxie golden I
don't live in this box
Novica morning
yoga boy out there what's your weight to
my ass
she's a dumpling lady damn DJ [ __ ]
you Kieran
she was so chamber doing it you know my
Osteopathy chance - oh no it'll be so
much each day Thank You Kumari okay
that was Devon lunch it'll have some
money Oracle database
thanks I smoked you awesome I got some
voluptuous lips moving in the game for
12 years though no confirmed bikini
taken ok stay you know I'm also a doctor
yes human mind double rejects I wish
something with a study know what she's
doing
her music actually pretty good regarding
her dream kind of late but tight yeah
she's doing it is she wants to
eventually bring them the New York club
scene she better start soon just because
I know you know milk expires just a job
I do every weird like seeing that on the
stage you know like because she doesn't
really get super hype with it and so
she's just kind of like her Energy's
like have you have you been to Japan
though no I have but I've never been
only Japan club scene
oh well I've been to we were in Japan
went to Disneyland and you're usually
pretty hype right when you're on a
roller coaster like rah Oh at least in
the u.s. we are but in Japan and one was
like scoop it was great because American
every turn but then look like this yeah
verify silently yeah so be with that
knowing that I can imagine their club
scene is like this is go this is [ __ ]
so sick and they're like
that's why are you even refusing I'm
going to please like I said the energy
she has energy that equates that to a
young person right you know me she
worships like so we are know that I'm
[Laughter]
just looking we're right now well that's
great you doing Japan is kind of like
that but even there like police officers
and fire trucks this excuse me it's
insane they do like how do you give them
a turtle in them when you're in Japan
oh they jump on they're like excuse me
please move out away thank you oh my god
so polite that is so polite that's what
we need here mr. music that's tight
I love her
[Music]
[Music]
oh she's counting us
that's [ __ ] awesome dude that's like
you know that Kenny strap shirt he's so
cute he's like a really popular
Christian musician
it was David Crowder David Crowder looks
like a homeless [ __ ] so when I was at a
it was called nasty world was the marine
world either way there was [ __ ] like
where was the bill he had a concert
there and so I had never seen David
Crowder once in my life oh this is gonna
be dope with wonder David Crowder
concerts and the cool I see this dude my
craggy ass clothes in a long as beer and
I want to skip though [ __ ] almost our
office things like I don't know so it's
a David Crowder even a homeless person
and I just I couldn't get I couldn't
move past that he's a personifying Jesus
yes mmm but even Jesus probably know you
look pretty dirty though I give her mad
props for wearing pretty shut because
most older women they get that flab
underneath their arms and they just
don't want to show it off anymore but
she's like the Pellegrin you have boxes
there was this other video that I got
ayrton know but she was wearing a sheer
shirt all I'm calling pink brought over
the shirt hi oh that's dull you know how
pole dancing yeah yeah which is this we
got into the whole deejay thing because
of a friend of hers a French man a
friend of hers all a love Lula French
man keeps 27 I was crazy finding you're
passionate like 70 something I'll [ __ ]
you awesome I feel like you're going to
have passions for the rest of your life
and I probably keep changing too yeah do
you change other person as you get older
but it's cool to always have something
like that because it makes life really
interesting and fun yeah yeah she's even
got the chance to spin and Paris oh wow
like someone's brought her out the guys
I gotta earn all the 27 year old hello
the chef of course the 27 year old
yeah a rich guy here and her beau does
another one okay I made it up I thought
they were [ __ ] yeah pretty sure they
are Jews not a lot of 80 year olds can
be accepted as being cool yeah they love
her he's in Tokyo pretty cool now we
know when we're oldest [ __ ] just don't
give a [ __ ] go to the nightclubs around
the 18
roles are at like go drinking getting a
[ __ ] frat your we cool yeah we talk
about all those people like the frat the
the yeah what sir was that one girl's
name the you're asking memory Queen oh
the grandmother smoked weed yeah just as
off they love her because you like just
doesn't you that's pretty dope it is
just me or how come like every time I
see like a an old person put on makeup
or put on red lipstick it looks like
they made a mistake but you have some
color it is what might be over dinner
that's weird looks like to me I don't
know I order this ah hello like
stretched out so now I just look like
this covers a lot of real estate yeah
hey guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
check it out up here
[Music]
you
[Music]